How long can you hold your
breath underwater? Apparently,
it won't be anywhere nearly as long as
Tom Cruise can — or the cast of Avatar.
During a presser for Avatar: The Way of Water,
Kate Winslet talked at some length about how
long she and her castmates held their breath
while filming underwater. Reportedly, Winslet
herself held her breath for seven minutes and
fifteen seconds on set, demolishing a
record previously held by Tom Cruise.
While filming Mission: Impossible — Rogue Nation,
Cruise was said to have held his breath
for six minutes to film an underwater
sequence. In a behind-the-scenes
featurette, Cruise said of the stunt:
"I had to prove to everyone
that it was actually safe,
and spend time with the safety guys and
the safety officers, and show them."
After surpassing Cruise by over a minute,
Winslet very much seemed to panic — in fact,
the actor momentarily thought she
was dead. Director James Cameron
was so stunned by Winslet's time that he
even seemed jealous. He told the press:
Though Winslet may hold Avatar's best
time underwater, one of her co-stars
could also have crushed Cruise's record.
Cameron estimated that Winslet outdid
even the film's diving trainers, but
he also noted that Sigourney Weaver
came "very close" to her co-star's time
underwater. Winslet jumped on the point,
eagerly explaining that the 73-year-old Hollywood
icon may have overtaken Tom Cruise's time as
well. Suggesting that Weaver's time may have
come to about "six-thirty," Winslet said:
For her part, the Alien star
seemed unbothered by whether or
not she exceeded Cruise's Mission
Impossible benchmark. She joked:
Winslet went on to briefly recount her
own record-breaking underwater experience,
stating that the first thing she said
upon resurfacing was that they needed to
radio the set — basically, she wanted Cameron to
know immediately that she had spent over
seven minutes underwater. Winslet added:
While having to perform underwater for extended
periods made Avatar: The Way of Water a unique
acting challenge for all involved, for Sigourney
Weaver specifically, the hurdles didn't end with
holding her breath. Her new character, Kiri, is
far different from her previous role in the Avatar
franchise, Dr. Grace Augustine, who was killed
off in the 2009 original. More specifically,
she's only a kid, meaning Weaver had to
totally alter her usual acting routine.
During an interview with Empire, Weaver
touched on what it was like portraying a
Na'vi teenager and the difficulties that
came with such a character. She said:
Nevertheless, she took the
task of playing a character
as young as Kiri as a welcome challenge. She adds: